[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRENT SHAFFER: to the
only PHP talk of Next.
It's really great to
have all guys here.
I am one of the few
PHP fanboys at Google.
So I want to you all know
that this is a safe place.
This is a sanctuary.
No one is going to
make fun of us here.
make fun of the fact
that our language acronym
stands for personal home page.
So today, I also have Mark
who is representing Instapage.
And Instapage is a San
Francisco-based startup
that does landing pages there.
If not the biggest, one
of the biggest landing
page products out there.
And he's going to give us some
practical solutions for how
they've used PHP
with Google Cloud
after I'm done with
some of the more
high-level technical stuff.
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: Perfect.
BRENT SHAFFER: a
little bit about me.
My name is Brent Shaffer.
I do a lot of open source
stuff here at Google.
So if you've used a PHP
client library to access APIs
at Google, you've probably
used something I've worked on.
Also if you've ever had
the extreme misfortune
of implementing an
OAuth two server in PHP,
you've probably used
my library also.
So to illustrate in applications
lifecycle across gool cloud
platform, I've built
a small app that
will take a face image, a base
image, and then swap them.
So nothing too
groundbreaking here,
but all this stuff is
available on GitHub
in case you want to run it.
The architecture is a WordPress
frontin, just for kicks.
And the back end is a Python
script that I found on GitHub.
And that's been containerized
into like a worker type back
end.
And so this is just supposed
to represent a pretty standard,
really basic Microsources
style set up.
The clicker.
Keep forgetting.
OK, so the first
thing that we're
going to do with
this application
is we're going to run
it on Compute Engine.
And some of the advantages
of Compute Engine
is we have this awesome Cloud
Launcher product that basically
has a bunch of stuff that
most PHP developers want
to run already set up, so
that you just click a button.
You can configure a couple
of things like HTTP,
HTTPS firewalls.
You can add PHP My Admin,
that kind of thing.
And we have those for
WordPress, LAMP stack.
We have it for Zen server also.
So if you're into that kind of
thing, you can run Zen server,
and we handle all of the
complicated licensing
and stuff.
And you just pay for it straight
through your billing account.
This is super low
barrier entry stuff.
I was actually going to
show you guys my blog.
Plug my blog,
brentertainment.com because I
split it up using this.
It took 20 minutes.
I launched a WordPress
instance using Cloud Launcher,
and then it was ready to go.
It's pretty great.
One other thing I
wanted to mention
is they have autoscaling
instance groups.
So even though it's
super simple stuff,
you can actually do pretty
complicated scaling rules
with it.
And then make a pretty
resilient application.
So this is what you get.
This is what my blog is.
It's just WordPress
running on MySQL in a VM.
So does anyone see
any problems with this
if you wanted to run this
at scale or something?
Does this seem like
it's a sweet solution?
We can all go home
once we run this.
So obviously running my
MySQL on the same instance
is not very scalable, right?
If you spin up a bunch
of these instances,
they're all not going to be
talking to the same database,
and it's not great.
So what I've done
for this example,
and this again took
very little time,
is I deployed my worker
container onto this Compute
Engine instance.
And then set up WordPress
to use Cloud SQL instead
of MySQL database that's
right there on the server.
So has anybody used Cloud SQL?
Is anyone familiar with this?
We just announced today that
we support Postgres and Cloud
SQL, which is pretty cool.
But it's essentially
just managed MySQL.
And that way you
don't have to worry
about setting up
master-slave replication,
or requisitioning
a big beefy server.
We take care of that stuff.
All right, so I'm going
to demo this real quick.
And feel free to follow
along on your cell phones.
The mobile UI is
actually really bad.
Actually the UI in
general is really bad.
I don't think the
Next branding team
is going to be super
stoked if they see this.
It's very simple.
You give it a very
happy picture of me.
And then I have
a load of images.
Does anybody have
anyone in particular
they would like to see
my face swapped with?
This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
BRENT SHAFFER: All right.
These are all public
domain images,
of course, that's
why I picked them.
So this now calling the
Pythons back end on local host.
And there you go.
Look at that.
That looks fantastic.
All right, sweet.
And go back to the slides.
So I'm actually running
this architecture, which
is just slightly different.
What I've done is
I've put WordPress
into a container that's running
on the Compute Engine instance.
Alongside the worker
docker container.
And that way they can still
communicate through local host.
And what's really
great about this
is this actually
really, really scalable.
This is a great design.
So I can set up
autoscaling instance groups
through Compute Engine to
scale this based-on requests
per second.
Things like that.
And what else?
CPU.
See CPU usage.
And/or you can actually use
custom metrics and stuff.
But this will now
scale to high heavens.
And if you really
wanted to scale
you could use spanner
instead of Cloud SQL there,
and then you're like
globally-scalable and crazy.
But the container part is
a significant step, right?
You can't just breeze over that.
So how many people here are
familiar with containers?
Or have built them?
I actually can't see anything
with these glasses on,
but I think I saw
a lot of hands.
That's great news.
So containers are one of our
favorite things here at Google.
We absolutely love containers.
If you want to know what to
get a Googler for Christmas,
get them a gift certificate
to The Container Store.
It's something he
can go and pick out
his favorite container.
We love these things.
We run these everywhere.
So to talk more
about containers,
I think a good
introduction is App Engine.
So once again App
Engine users-- has
anyone here used App Engine?
OK, slightly less but
still a lot of people.
So we announced today the
GA of App Engine Flex.
Which is really great.
App Engine Flex is similiar
to App Engine Standard,
but we run like standard
container format--
Docker containers.
So you can take pretty
much any container
and stick in App Engine.
And you get all the
advantages of App Engine,
but you're running your
own custom container.
Which is really sweet.
So what we've done--
the few PHP-loving
Googlers at Google--
is we've spent a lot of
time building this base
image for you PHP applications.
And this thing is
available on GitHub.
And it went into Beta
this week or last week.
So, it's great.
And we would love your
feedback, obviously, on it.
Because PHP-- as all
of you guys know,
there's a broad user base with
tons of different types of PHP
users.
And we're trying to come
up with a runtime that's
really great for everybody.
So how does this work?
So when you use
App Engine, it just
copies over your
application code, built
and on top of the base PHP
image that we've built.
And then it deploys the
resulting container.
Right?
And this container is built
into Google Container Registry.
GCR dot IO.
And if you're not familiar
with that, that's really basic.
It's just like
Docker Hub, so it's
like a repository for images.
Every time you deploy
a App Engine app,
it gets put into this URL that
represents your project ID.
The version and service
that you just built.
So that's really
cool too because you
can take that image,
and you could deploy it
to Compute Engine or
to Amazon or run it
locally or to Container Engine.
Which is what we're going
to talk about later.
So some of the advantages
of using our base image
is we automatically install
all of your dependencies,
if you're using Composer, or
you have a Composer dot lock.
Which you all should be doing.
We support all the non-end
of life versions of PHP
and will continue to as new
versions become available.
We have good logging and
error-handling integration
with Google Cloud products.
We're using Nginx,
which is great.
Apache is also great.
And we don't dislike
Apache and, in fact,
if there was a public
outcry for Apache support
it would be pretty
trivial to add it.
The problem is it's huge.
So it adds like a
significant amount of size
to the resulting
image, which slows down
uploading and deployment
and stuff like that.
Nginx is also great.
So we've had a lot
of luck with that.
And that's what we
use in the container.
So PHP-- any configuration.
Everyone's going to have
some customization required.
So you can enable a set
of shared extensions
that we've already
compiled into the runtime.
Or you can add whatever custom
configuration that you need.
And you just drop that any file
in the root of your project,
and we load it.
And same thing goes with the
web server configuration.
So with Nginx, if you drop
an Nginx dash app dotcom,
we load that configuration and
run that for the container.
So some security
changes, since secure
is in the title of this talk.
PHP and your extensions
are kept up to date.
So like I said,
all the supported
versions of those extensions--
or sorry of PHP that we have
when minor releases come out,
we keep that
regularly up to date.
So when you build on
the player container
you get the latest version.
We also have security patches.
So a little bit on this,
because I think it's
a really cool thing
that we've done.
How many of you guys have
used parce, underscore, STR?
Or seen that function?
Nobody?
Wait this can't be real.
This guy over here.
OK.
We've got one.
This is like a really
common PHP function.
It takes a query string
formatted string and splits it
apart into key value
pairs in an array.
So if you haven't used it, all
the libraries that you're using
have used it.
So this function is great.
But if you don't supply a
second argument, instead
of loading those
variables into an array,
it loads them into
the current scope
that the function is being
called in as variables.
So you can see why that would
be a security issue, right?
If you have a dollar
sign Admin equals false,
and then I type dollars
sign Admin equals true.
In the query string
and that variable
is going to be overwritten.
So this is like
not good behavior.
This is PHP from
over 10 years ago,
whenever people were doing
terrible things with registered
globals and stuff like that.
So we don't want that.
We don't want that at all.
This is what we're trying to
fight as PHP developers, all
those haters.
They keep saying that
our language isn't secure
because of stuff like this.
So what we've done in our
runtime, is we've patched this.
So you can't do this.
You'll just get an error that
you need two argument, which
is really good.
We also have-- for PHP 5.6 only.
Unfortunately, just for PHP 5.6
because it's not stable for 7.0
and above.
We have Suhosin
security extension.
And this is a really, really
good security extension.
Currently what it
does for 5.6 is
it logs potentially unsafe
functions that you might call.
Like [INAUDIBLE] pass
through and things like that.
And they'll show up
in cloud loggers.
So you can audit your
own application code
to see how safe it is.
But it does
additional things too.
It makes sure that your C
extensions-- the C calls
are doing improper
things with memory.
Like buffer overflow
and stuff like that.
It's good to have that in there.
We don't use HT access,
which is generally
considered not good practice.
And we have appropriate
file permissions and user
permissions for the
code that you deploy.
So it's not executing as root,
and the files aren't writable.
Stuff like that.
OK.
Talked a lot.
So the two files that
you need-- and this still
isn't App Engine.
This is just a container
for your application,
which is really nice.
The two files that you
need is PHP dot, INI.
This one.
And this is for whatever
PHP configurations you have.
For this app in particular,
I'm using the GD extension
to do some image manipulation.
So I've added that
to my INI file.
I've increased the
maximum amount of uploads,
so that you can upload
100 faces if you want.
And it might explode,
I don't know.
But you can do it.
We have a few other
extensions that
are installed for WordPress,
BC Math, and Opcache.
So we also have the
Nginx configuration file.
And this is all that's
required for WordPress.
And you actually don't need
this if you're using our default
configuration.
But I assume that most people
want to add this anyway.
But this basically just points
to the front controller.
So all modern frameworks these
days use front controllers.
So that's essentially
all this is used for.
And then for WordPress you have
a special rewrite for WP Admin.
So if you're deploying
to App Engine Flex now,
you need one additional
file, which is app dot yaml.
And if you've used
the App Engine,
you've used app dot yaml before.
This is basically just
a configuration file
that tells App Engine how
to deploy your application.
So in this case,
we have runtime PHP
to let it know it needs a
build from our PHP base image.
And we have Mflex to
deploy to App Engine
Flexible environment.
The runtime configuration
thing just says,
our front controllers is
in the root of our project.
So if you had Symfony, it
would be document root web.
If you had Laravel, it would
be document root public.
And then the rest of this
isn't super important,
but you can set environment
variables in app.yaml.
And if you're using
Cloud SQL version two,
you declare your
connection there.
And it looks like this.
This is basically the
same as what we have,
but now we have two
separate services.
Instead of two services
contained in an instance.
So some advantages
of App Engine.
We have versioning with
containers and URLs,
which is really nice.
So every time you deploy, you
get a time-stamped version
for the image and a URL as well.
Representing that
version you deployed.
We have autoscaling, of course.
And you have default
SSL and Apps Swapp
dotcom, which is nice.
So let's go back to the demo.
Now here's Faceswap
on App Engine.
Is there anyone else
you guys want to see?
If not I'm going to choose.
I might go with Ronald Reagan.
This one's really good, because
I apparently look exactly
like Ronald Reagan.
[LAUGHTER]
Faceswapping has no effect.
So if we look at App
Engine in Pantheon here.
Sorry.
You see we have a
default service, which
is our WordPress container.
And then a worker, which
is the Python service.
So I don't know how
interactive this crowd is.
But if you guys all want to
access this on your phones
and start actually face-swapping
with it from images
from your phones, we can
actually see these scale up.
And that's pretty fun.
So I would love it
if you guys did that.
I actually haven't
done this before.
So I think it would be fun.
The URL was gae dot face
swapp, like two P's.
F-A-C-E-S-W-A-P-P dot com.
Then that will load this up.
You can also go to cloud dash
next dash PHP dot appspot dot
com.
It just redirects.
And in the meantime, I'm
going to upload a couple more.
Let's see if this works.
That's a terrible one.
I know I should delete it.
Depending on how many
people are doing this,
this might not work.
Is anybody actually
face-swapping out there?
I'm just curious.
Raise your hand if you are.
OK.
We got one.
We got a handful of people.
OK.
So this should definitely work.
Should definitely work.
When I tested this, it only
took two different attempts
overloading the worker.
I sent in 20, and within
seconds it spun up five more.
So I'm hoping the same
thing happens now.
Come on, Yeah!
OK.
We got another one, sweet.
All right.
That's App Engines.
That's basic.
All right, let's go
back to the slides.
OK, so we're going to talk
about Container Engine now.
So moving an application
to Container Engine,
now that you've done
all these other things,
is hilariously easy.
There's not even really a step.
You could literally take the
image that App Engine uses
and deploy it to
Container Engine.
And you're ready to go.
So it's really simple.
One of the cool features
that we have is--
let's say you do have
a complicated app.yaml
or something.
You can generate a Docker file
that represents the container
that App Engine builds just
with a single G Cloud command.
That's gcloud, app, gen,
config, dash, dash custom.
And so that gets
you a Docker file.
I haven't really explained
what Dock file is yet,
so that is essentially the
standard Docker container
format for building
your container.
And I'll show you an example
of that in the next slide.
So after you've done that,
you run a Docker command
to build the Docker image.
And then a G Cloud command
to upload that image
to Google Container Registry.
Which again, is
like a Docker hub.
It's just a repository for
all of your container images.
So this is what you need
for this app in particular.
You need a configuration file
for the two different services.
Our WordPress app
and our Worker app.
And you need a configuration
file that just--
this just establishes
a load balancer.
So you get an IP
for your service.
This is what a
Dockerfile looks like.
This is the one I
use in this app.
It's incredibly basic.
All it does is say, we're
using the PHP base image.
The Google App Engine PHP
base image, so there it is.
And then your
application is going
to be installed in
the app directory.
That's what got generated.
So these are taken by
Kubernetes and Kubernetes
is container orchestration.
So in comparison
with what we did
in Compute Engine, what we
had was just two containers
running on the VM.
With Kubernetes, we're
now going to have
a fleet of these containers
that we can scale up and scale
down individually.
And we have a lot more control
and management with them.
And I'll demonstrate that later.
But this is the big value add
of using Container Engine.
So this configuration file
is actually really simple.
It may look daunting, but
really all we're doing
is adding some
arbitrary labels here.
So we can have fire-grained
control over these containers.
We are just letting it know
that we need a load balancer
for our WordPress service.
So there's a WordPress
configuration.
You'll see we have a image
path, using GCR dot IO,
so it always pulls
the latest image.
And we let it know we're
running in the container running
on port 8080.
And we again give
it some labels so it
knows how to reference
this container later.
And we also have three
of them going on.
This is our worker.
It looks pretty much identical.
We have a different image
path, different labels for it.
And we're going to
use two of those.
So I already showed
you guys how to build.
This is the same thing whenever
you deploy these things.
You run Kube CTL apply.
And Kube CTL actually is
already on your machine
if you use G Cloud.
And I assume everyone
here uses G Cloud.
So it's already there.
You can just run this
command, and you're
going to deploy these
pods to Container Engine.
The architecture of this
looks pretty much identical
to what we had before.
Now we just have Container
Engine pods, instead of
App Engine instances.
And the difference here
is pod is basically just
like this conceptual--
it's one level of abstraction
above the Compute Engine
instances that
you're running on.
And this just allows you to
have multiple containers running
in pods, and then you
can take multiple pods
and run them across
your instances.
Your Compute Engine instances.
So demo time.
Once again.
All right.
This time I'm going to do my
other favorite, which is Jack
Nicholson from "The Shining."
So he looks really angry,
but now he's happy.
Actually I think
that one is probably
scarier than his other face.
So to highlight how
powerful Kubernetes is,
I'm just going to switch to
the terminal real quickly.
And edit the one file
that I showed you
up there for the worker.
We can see we have two
replicas right down here.
Everybody see that.
So I'm going to add zero, and
then just run that same command
that I did before.
Kube CTL, apply.
Now if I do get pods--
Oops, I got to do it quick.
They're already up.
That wasn't that wasn't good,
because you didn't actually see
that they weren't out before.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What means
[INAUDIBLE] ready, two over two?
BRENT SHAFFER:
OK, good question.
So this is a list of the pods.
And inside ready
is the containers.
So two of two
containers are ready.
So for our Faceswap
worker pod, we
have just one container running.
And that's the face swap script.
For our WordPress worker,
or our WordPress pods,
we have two containers inside.
One is for the actual face
swap WordPress container.
That we built and deployed
that we talked about.
And one is something that I
didn't talk about, because I
didn't want to confuse anybody.
But it's not that confusing.
So there is a Cloud SQL proxy
running in another container.
This Cloud SQL proxy.
So if we look at
this original file
that I had after this
container configuration,
I have another
container configuration
that basically spins up
from another container
image a proxy server.
So the WordPress
instance is communicating
with a proxy server, which
communicates a Cloud SQL.
And that's how Cloud
SQL version two works.
I don't know if anybody
here that works at Google
has a good explanation
for why that is.
I don't actually know.
But if you use something like
spanner, which is something
we announced recently.
And it's an awesome database.
You won't need to do that.
You'll just connect
directly to it.
But that's good,
because it illustrates
some of the nuances
of Kubernetes
that you don't have to deal
with if you use App Engine.
If you use App
Engine, you don't need
to spin up a Cloud SQL proxy.
App Engine environment
handles that for you.
Just connect to the
database directly.
And it also illustrates how pods
contain multiple containers.
And then the containers can
communicate on Localhost
within the ports.
Which is really nice.
OK, so what I was going to do.
I just want to do
this real quickly.
Because I just love
how seamless this is.
So I just spun it
back down to two.
It happens so fast.
Whoops.
Not that.
Lets do 30, what the heck.
I haven't done that yet.
I don't know if that'll work.
OK, there we go.
We already have most
of them running.
Sweet.
So for my final
trick, let's just
blast this thing with
all of these images
and see what happens.
Come on, come on.
OK, they're coming in.
That's good.
It's actually a little
slower than I expected it.
So I really like the acquirer
currency guy up here.
I think they all
actually look better.
I really like the
statue of David.
That one is nice.
I like his build.
It's a little
better than my own.
OK, so let's go
back to the slides.
So we talked about Google
Compute Engine, which
is less managed, but it's
an incredible low barrier
of entry.
And it actually has the
ability to be very scalable.
In just one second,
Marek is going
to come up and talk
about how they've
built a global and very
scalable application using
that paradigm that I showed
you with containers running
inside a Compute
Engine instance.
We've talked about
Google App Engine, which
is a lot more managed,
it's highly scalable.
And we talked about Google
Container Engine, which
is maybe higher of
a barrier of entry,
but once you get
used to it you have
an insane amount of options you
can deploy tons of services.
And manage them very easily.
So are there any questions?
Sorry.
We have Q&A at the end.
And we're going to do
all the questions then?
But is anybody like confused,
before I hand it over to Marek?
Or does this all make sense?
OK.
Sweet.
We'll be back for
questions in just a minute.
So without further ado, come on.
Please applaud Marek.
He's great.
[APPLAUSE]
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: Hello everyone.
I'm quite confused
why I was invited,
because we use Amazon AWS.
[LAUGHTER]
No, just kidding.
Sure we have plenty of nice
experience with Google Cloud
platform.
We moved to Google Cloud
platform in January 2016,
and it took over three
months to learn and evaluate
various products,
Go Cloud products
against our application.
What I did?
OK, and before I start, I'll
give you a quick background
about Instapage and me.
I am chief architect
in Instapage.
And I joined Instapage
six years ago.
And since it's very beginning,
I've seen growth from the start
to the end.
And Instagpage is the
most powerful landing page
marketing solution.
And it requires
solid infrastructure.
Our application seems
to be scalable, but not
in the right way.
And speaking to my
colleagues, I had the metaphor
that we have a fleet of buses--
40 seats and one
wheelchair space each one.
And we thought we have
a capacity to scale.
But when we've have a spike
in need of wheelchair spaces,
we are not efficient.
Because, for example, we have
to send 10 buses for 10 people,
which requires wheelchair space.
And referring to our
application, which
the situation was exactly that.
We needed something
more flexible.
Because if all traffic came
to our monolithic app and said
there were some bottlenecks.
And tie up application
crashed, costs downtime.
And after experiments with
two Kubernetes and Docker,
it was clear that
the orchestration
is the right direction.
So our system to
scale, we decided
to chop it and split it
into small independent micro
services.
But gradually.
First we took out an
[INAUDIBLE] storage system,
which you can see on the right.
And then we made landing
page server system
for our clients' landing pages.
And as you see on this
diagram, after transition,
our [INAUDIBLE] was smaller.
The database with smaller too.
And it had to
handle less traffic.
And most of our traffic was
directed to lightweight.
Lightweight-dedicated and
ultra-scaled microservices.
And serving landing pages, we
observed that changes in load
was very viable
and unpredictable.
And even we had a
lot of spike loads.
So we needed some kind of
sophisticated automated system
that could scale
up and scale down.
So what we designed was
something like a reverse proxy.
And we made it and
trapped into Docker to--
easy to start them.
Because start time
was very crucial,
we even created an
instance template,
which preloaded a Docker
image to spawn them
as fast as possible.
And then everything we
combine in back end services
with out of scale turn the DOM.
And all traffic is going through
the HTP load browser, which I
was asked us to direct traffic.
Direct it zone where
visitor is from.
So visitors from US
will see the content
donated by instances in US.
From Europe in Europe.
And from Asia to Asia.
And that was a perfect
solution for our needs.
Each instance has been tested
to and proved that it can
handle 200 requests per second.
And with minimal of five because
we have found five zones.
Three in the US.
One in Europe, and one in Asia.
We could handle 1000
requests per second.
And if traffic exceeds--
it's more than 150 requests
per second for an instance,
the system created new
ones to handle the traffic.
And if traffic was
going down, system
was taking down not
needed instances.
And real life traffic, which
looks like sometimes like that.
Some customers inform us that
they do expect high load,
but some do not.
And even if with traffic like
that and out of school system
using out of scale
back ends and Docker,
we are able to handle this kind
of traffic without human input.
Descale.
It could be a day.
Normal it looks like an
[INAUDIBLE] sometimes.
BRENT SHAFFER: Quick
question for you Marek.
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: Sure.
BRENT SHAFFER: What's the upper
bounds on that graph there?
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: Which one?
BRENT SHAFFER: The upper bounds.
You have 1,000
requests per second,
and then it goes up to--
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: --Yes.
I do predict that
some people create
a campaign using AdWords.
And they tend to stop
it for some reason.
Or they are also running out.
For some reason, the traffic
drops, and then it comes up.
If their campaign is resumed
or something like that.
And our system has to handle
500,000 registered users, who
made 1.5 million pages.
And traffic to these pages
generates 20 to 50 requests
per second.
Just normally, when you
see the smallest usage.
But the high record we
recorded was 12,000 requests
per second, and
even over that time
the system was fully functional.
Because it created 60 instances.
That was obviously DDOS combined
with [INAUDIBLE] traffic.
But we had to handle it,
at least for the beginning.
And we have done great work,
and we have more efficiency
and scalability.
And much more stable platform.
And we are ready
to grow even more.
Thank you.
BRENT SHAFFER: So
while you're up here,
I have a quick question?
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: Sure.
BRENT SHAFFER: You said you
have six micro services,
plus WordPress front end, plus
a PHP back end that is gradually
being split.
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: Exactly.
The diagram I showed
you in the beginning
is like nothing
what have in real.
Yes we have what's called
PHP application, WordPress,
and for [INAUDIBLE]
services Because I count--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRENT SHAFFER: And those
are all containerized,
and they're running on a
single Compute Engine instance.
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: Exactly, yes.
And thank you that
you told that,
because we do
containerize everything.
Because we want
to use Kubernetes
to manage our deployments.
And just to manage it.
BRENT SHAFFER: A follow
up question then would be,
of course--
it seems like it's a good fit
for a Kubernetes deployment.
So I'm curious why you
guys made the decision
to use Docker and Compute
Engine, as opposed
to going with Container Engine?
MAREK DAJNOWSKI:
Yes that was why we
are containerizing everything.
BRENT SHAFFER: Got you.
I really like your guys' story.
I think it's really cool.
Because it shows where a lot
of PHP applications are, right?
I have personally been involved
with many PHP applications that
follow this trend of starting
with a massive monolithic
application.
That was built a
while ago, and it's
being split off because
it no longer scales well.
Or just because it's
very hard to manage.
So you guys are
in-between, where
you have moved away from the
monolithic PHP app stage.
But you're still
transitioning to
the fully-orchestrated via
Kubernetes slash Container
Engine fleet of containers.
So it's obviously a long process
to move an application to that.
You mentioned that you guys
have four or five other
microservices that you're--
MAREK DAJNOWSKI: In
development, yes.
BRENT SHAFFER: That
they are in development,
and that you guys are going
to deploy pretty soon.
So at that point, you're looking
at a very strong use-case
for something like Kubernetes.
Because those services are not
going to scale equally, right?
You're going to want to
scale some more than others
and everything else.
One of the advantages
of Kubernetes
I also wanted to highlight--
using Container
orchestration in general--
is whenever you're pushing
updates and rolling updates
for this stuff, like I did.
Which was in a very,
very small scale.
But when you're talking about
a very big scale, like Marek
is doing, you can use
the tags and the labels--
you can do rolling updates.
Kubernetes actually has support
for just doing rolling updates.
So it'll take down
half your pods
and deploy the new pods
pretty much transparently.
But another advantage is
if you have-- coupling
between these microservices.
Where let's say you
have an interface that's
going to break compatibility.
And so the way that
these two microservices
talk to each other has to
be updated at the same time.
Kubernetes makes it
very easy to do that,
as well, using those labels.
So as long as you have
the proper labels,
you can roll over those
services together.
So I'm personally
not a DevOps guy,
which is probably
why I absolutely love
containerisation in general.
And then also, even more
so, Kubernetes and Container
Engine.
Because it makes
me the DevOps guy.
I don't do the bash scripts.
At every other job
I've worked at,
I turn over the application
code to these guys that
are building RPMs, and they
live inside their terminal.
And they're super fast
typers and have all hot keys.
And that's not me.
But this kind of stuff
makes that very accessible.
And it makes you
feel like you do have
good oversight to your DevOps.
So actually, because
we have extra time,
I'd like to turn it back
over to my demo real quick.
And show one other thing.
So you guys already saw
the fleet of containers
that we deployed
on a command line.
So if you're using
Container Engine--
we have this great little
dashboard that you can run.
Oh, I messed up.
And this helps you
visualize your cluster.
Oh man.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRENT SHAFFER: Oh, thanks, guys.
There she is.
So the reason why this
is indicating a warning
is because I spun up too many.
So I spun up 30, but I only have
four Compute Engine instances
that are available.
So there's a handful
of these pods that
couldn't be deployed,
because they
have a minimum amount of
requirements that can't be met.
So whether it's CPU
requirements or something else.
Yes.
This is CPU requirements.
So one of the primary
tenets of Kubernetes
is that it abstracts your
container orchestration
from the hardware
that it runs on.
Or the VMs that it runs on.
So the scaling of the pods
happens automatically.
And it happens
separately from the VMs
that you give Kubernetes.
Because Kubernetes is going
to take care of all that.
It's going to make
sure that it schedules
the pods in the right
places and the best places.
So in this case, if I
gave it a super beefy VM,
and then I gave it a one
CPU, horrible old VM,
it's going to use that if it
can for resources that it can.
To make the best of it.
So that's pretty much it.
Kubernetes-- it does
get very complicated.
I think one of the
things I wanted
to show in this presentation
is that it doesn't have to be.
There's a lot of really,
really good resources
out there on Kubernetes.
And so I don't need
to be another one.
There's a udacity course
online on Kubernetes.
That's great.
There's a lot of YouTube
videos and presentations
that have happened at other
Google conferences that
are great.
But, hopefully, you
guys get the feeling
that you can take an
existing PHP application,
or whichever one that you're
planning to build next,
and give this a try.
Give containers a chance
because they're great.
And Kubernetes itself
can be a little bit
intimidating at
first, because you do
have these configuration
files and stuff.
Which is why App
Engine is great, right?
You just G Cloud app, deploy.
Your containers are
running in the cloud.
It's a good way to
dip your toe in.
And then when you're
ready for the next step,
you can go ahead and pull
those containers down
and start running a whole
fleet of these things.
And that's pretty fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]